good morning it's Tuesday I had like the
best weekend ever watching the football
first in London and then in Wales and
now I am home and jet lagged and I guess
going back to college so when my
children were younger and I watched
their soccer games I would sometimes
think if you let me out onto that field
right now I would destroy those
seven-year-olds like I'm an
exceptionally poor soccer player but 45
year old me could score a lot of goals
in seven-year-old soccer like I don't
know how to say this generously but even
the quote-unquote good seven-year-old
soccer players are in fact terrible
anyway this is kind of how I have
imagined going back to college like I
have less free time now than I did when
I was 19 but I am so much more capable
and prepared I was just never a good
student I sort of felt like school was
the price you had to pay in order to
live life which wasn't about history or
literature but was about friendships and
obsessive crushes and binge drinking for
whatever reason I never quite understood
that the point of school is not actually
to get a degree or fulfill expectations
or whatever the point of school is to
better understand the universe and your
place in it but then after I got out of
school I did fall in love with learning
like over the last year I have read a
ridiculous number of books about
tuberculosis even though learning about
TB is in no way my job like and this is
not the point of the video but did you
know that in 2022 more people died of
tuberculosis than died of homicide War
malaria typhoid and cholera combined
tuberculosis a disease that is almost
always curable nonetheless kills a
million and a half people per year why
did I grow up thinking that TB was
primarily a disease of 19th century
poets why is the world not on fire with
the Injustice of tuberculosis these are
very interesting questions to me and I
am exploring them in my free time for
fun which would have been very difficult
to explain to my 19 year old self also
I'm just like much more capable and
confident than I was back then like in
19 99 it required a significant outlay
of energy for me to write a three-page
paper but now I can do that I mean I
write a three-page paper every Tuesday
but all that noted I am of course
romanticizing the Collegiate learning
experience right like when I fantasize
about going back to college I only think
about taking courses that fit my
interests and talents which is not
College as most people experience it
like at most universities college is not
made up entirely of classes called like
the captain of all these men of death
toward a social history of tuberculosis
you also have to take classes called
like uh math so Hank you've just
announced study hall a partnership
between complexly Arizona State
University and Google to offer a
pipeline from educational YouTube video
to actual college credit and I just
think it's brilliant like you pay 25 to
sign up and take a course and then only
after you've finished and received a
grade do you decide if you want to pay
for college credit this can lower the
overall cost of college education in the
U.S but critically it also means that
you don't have to take on a bunch of
loans before you even start and find out
if a program's approach to learning is
right for you I'm so overwhelmed by how
awesome it is that I've signed up to
take two classes starting in March one
is of course that aligns with my
romantic notion of going back to college
a class in American history up to 1865.
I feel like I should do okay in that one
but the other Hank is a terrifying
Specter on the horizon math I'm in favor
of math I know that it's beautiful when
people who love math talk to me about
how and why they love it I feel their
enthusiasm and wonder but it is so hard
for me I just barely got out of high
school math with c's and D's can I pass
college math we'll find out starting in
March if you want to learn more about
study hall there are links in the
doobly-doo to go studyhall.com in the
study hall YouTube channel Hank I
continue to be astonished by the stuff
you helped bring into the world I will
see you on Friday